sipping is king [ __ ] okay listen this is
a safe space for all Simpson like and
yeah so don't you you you be here and
you you simp okay you do your thing you
do your thing you already know what was
on you do your thing but when someone is
talking about guys sipping for a girl I
just don't understand what's wrong with
like worshiping a girl there's nothing
wrong with that okay girls deserve to be
worshipped all right not saying
specifically me okay but girl should be
worshipped all right it doesn't mean
you're a synth all right something isn't
bad same thing is King [ __ ] okay
you're a king if you're if you're not
afraid to sit I think she gave me the
Corona in my head in her name well she's
a cam girl so I'm sure she loves simple
because the people who donate to camp
girls are simps what are your thoughts
on sibling and sibling culture do you
know what a simp is that's like a pimp
without the P in it and they becomes the
opposite okay explain something is this
basically pandering symp a simple person
lacking common sense a fool a simpleton
a man who foolishly over values a woman
and puts her on a pedestal
I like that definition so with that
definition what are your thoughts on
sippin culture guys would pay for cam
girls who pay for only fans who worship
these madmen there's a service for
people you know I mean you do it I don't
care I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna
engage in so you're doing it but you
don't think the fact that as a culture
of a whole bunch of men are valuing
women only for their looks specifically
and then paying them for that you don't
think that is bad
it's what the society is right it's what
it's been happening right and then
that's there's that role it happens it's
what it is
I'm gonna disagree with you I think
ahead I think anybody who goes out there
and basically says some with someone you
can't be wrong you can't do wrong
because you're good-looking or I'm going
to worship you just because of that
no no that's good there's there's agrees
to it do you know what I mean like when
you wouldn't I slip you guys when guys
simp they will protect people who do
terrible things when guys simp they will
make excuses for people who do terrible
things
yeah I'm like how many times as a girl
doesn't and they I see [ __ ] simply for
these bras and I was I was not really
talking about that level but I see what
you're saying were you coming at the
question was what do you think about
people that pay for camgirl and that's
what I read was responding to okay I
don't care you pay for captain girls do
things you like oh yeah this former same
thing do it when it comes to the degree
where you're only agreeing with that I
mean I've seen women do it I've seen men
do it I've seen people like some people
can do no wrong because they're stars
they put them on a pedestal of course
not right I don't agree with that well
it's not like I hear things like that
like oh it doesn't look like a wine
theme or he doesn't look like a bad guy
I'm like that's not how the world works
so when you base yourself on looks yeah
that's different this where it becomes
problem it's like that Disney complex
mmm well it's not a tease the complex
that's not how we call it but you know
every bad person had like sharp pointy
teeth and dark complexion oh well that's
a bad guy eat a little like a bad guy he
don't look like that that's how you get
caught because you were pacing yourself
on the looks remember that person they
cannot do anything I can't believe that
that person in that
well I can't that person is a human
should women be worshipped in general
take it however you want it
nobody should be worship worship is a
strong ABS term to do with someone or
shape someone my relationship reversed
worshipping it asked with the church I
worship anyone Oh a girl told me she
wanted to worship me I'm like no I mean
maybe further I'll baptize you with this
and then you could leave because you
only get baptized once in your life
you're welcome but after that no I don't
watch your show yeah that's weird
people get baptized multiple times more
than that once yeah well if you get
baptized when you're Catholic and then
you change religions you got to get
baptized when you do put them with you
all right well that's a different priest
I work for one team team ABBA okay you
want to go somewhere else you go
listen worship I don't know about that
boo-boo
there is definitely a culture of
untalented women who basically use their
sex appeal online in order to garner
fans and garner money do I get mad about
it
no do I think it's good no do I think it
should be allowed to remain yes because
if guys want to be sips they should be
allowed to be simps and you should be
allowed to mock them free society yeah
there but I'm not gonna sit here and say
simply it's a good thing it's a terrible
thing if I was raising a son and he was
a simp I would mock him and I would say
that's trash it's pathetic worshipping
someone putting them on a pedestal
immediately lowering yourself why would
you do that why would you do that with
anybody celebrities and YouTube cameras
I don't get that guys were throwing
their money at these broads just because
of the looks and it like makes them feel
somehow like to me it's just pathetic it
is I hate the fact that these broads
play video games as a means to appeal to
the nerdy and like basically most
desperate men amongst us it's really
doing it because it doesn't need yeah
the analyse what it is I'm like okay
there's a need in there I'm gonna fill
the void I just I get it it's just men's
desperation for like interaction with
women they get to the point where their
pain just to be there there's something
gross about simply makes you a kink no
come Paula come you're just talking da
da there's something funny about camp
grows where they have their cleavage out
like just really pop in there playing
video games there's a reason for that it
works I never said this is work I didn't
say that a lot of things work yeah
doesn't mean the right yeah doesn't mean
I'm gonna do it either yeah we could do
our videos in chess because that's one
of some of the ladies want I want to do
that that's not me yeah I could
definitely say some [ __ ] and get all
the ladies on board with this but you
rather hate on them yeah what if your
daughter was doing that would it bother
that's a great question what is we
believe in everyone's individual freedom
and I agree with that
now it's someone close to you when do
you feel a sort of
since my girl she is simple or taking
repeating profits or reaping the profits
off my family a boss you think the money
take all the money yeah I don't know no
the real answer is I don't know it's
like you know somewhere else saying to
me like will you let your daughter strip
I'm like no but you say you respect
strippers yeah there are some places and
some things that I don't want my kids to
be in yeah so I mean I don't respect
that it's like going to the army I
respect soldiers but I don't listen you
want my kids to go to the army and go
off fighting a war that is not theirs
no I don't respect Kim gross and I don't
want my you don't I don't respect him
girls I'm sorry listen get your money do
your thing I'm not gonna go out of here
of my own way to hate not gonna do that
not writing statuses I'm not doing that
not making a whole but not doing
anything but if you AskMe my honest
opinion no I do think there's something
dishonorable about it only only because
the clientele is gross and disrupt like
are you an example I know cam gross and
they tell me how disgusting some of the
men are some of the stuff they had to go
through getting doxxed having people
stay and I'm just like it's unfortunate
that men have to be that gross but you
also go back there because of it's like
you're willing to leverage your
potential security because the fact that
there's easy cash in head right there's
a payoff for everything it's like being
an artist freedom you know you get to do
all that no financial security so if
[ __ ] goes south you're not getting a
whole bunch of benefits you go sounds
you get a sunburn same thing with this
it's like you know what the clientele is
it's generally pretty nasty fare so if
you're engaging I'm like why would you
like if our YouTube fans we're not
becoming better or didn't learn anything
from what we're doing I wouldn't engage
in this work I think what you provide to
the people and who your target audience
is matters it does say a lot about the
work that you want to do right yeah but
this is just ideas I'm not ironclad in
my opinion on this I'm pretty flexible I
was just kind of thinking it through but
we want to hear your thoughts what do
you guys think about simple you're
flexible on this topic
show them that makes your tie
and they just okay so let us know what
you guys think about flexibility we want
to hear your comments below there's
something gross up up and may it puts
people to school puts people to school
what do you mean pick it face people's
bill that's what I mean oh you still
going through that strippers paying for
college
Malchus strippers sugar baby
and a small it's a small hanging for
time by the way is this mob hanging for
college it's a small percentage of them
paying for college paying France
you